have you ever wondered why so many
people are gay these days so let me get
the straight so traditionalist people
being born before 1946 only 1.7% of them
are part of the lgbtq community baby
boomers are at 2.7% Gen X is 3.3%
Millennials born from 1981 to 1996 or
11.2% and gen Z kids born from 1997 to
2004 20% 1 out of five really that's
really naturally that's how they work
have you ever wondered why there are so
many genders all of a sudden I'm Cody
pronouns e m a SS or z z z z or really
any Neo pronouns that aren't Z her
her now don't get me wrong I've got
plenty of gay friends and I'm in the
camp of you can do whatever you want
with your life as long as you don't hurt
others but it's still a question worth
asking why is there so much gender
fluidity these days why now some say
it's natural some say it's cultural but
in actuality there's a good chance that
at least part of it might be chemical
this is Dr Shanna Swan who's a renowned
statistician and back in the 9s she was
tasked by the National Academy of
Sciences to investigate whether or not
sperm count was declining At first she
knew nothing about the subject she
didn't have a strong opinion on it and
that's why she thinks she was asked to
doist because she was unbiased so she
took the job one of the first things we
did was to look at this paper that had
come out a few years earlier out of
Denmark and this paper was alarming
because it said that sperm count had
dropped 50% in the prior 50 years okay
came out in '92 all right and so the
committee asked me as a statistician
which is what my doctorate is in to look
at this and tell the committee whether
this is something they could you know
consider for their work on the you know
in this committee so I looked at the
paper and I have to say I was not
impressed why weren't you impressed well
first of all it was very thin in terms
of number of words and pictures and data
and the data that were there if I had a
graph I could show it to but but you've
seen it in I think maybe yeah and a lot
of the data were in recent years they
were kind of spotty over the time period
and more importantly perhaps there were
not you know any of the factors that we
worry about which might cause an
erroneous decline none of those were
considered this is from the concrete
podcast by the way which has just been
rebranded to the Danny Jones podcast I'm
a huge fan I love Danny's interviews and
you should definitely subscribe with the
link
below because Dr Swan was not happy with
that study she dedicated 6 months to
investigate practically every single
study out there on sperm count to see if
there was indeed something here somebody
approaching this might think well okay
that went down because you know in more
recent years the men were older that
could make it down somewhat actually
sperm count doesn't decline dramatically
with age so that might be a small factor
maybe the men are more stressed that's
probably happening and stress actually
does lower sperm count okay and the men
could have been more obese and obesity
lowers sperm count and maybe most
importantly you might ask well maybe the
way we count sperm has changed so that
in recent years the counting method
counts lower you know methods change and
maybe they're not exactly the same over
the 50 years right and finally there was
the question of who are these men and
maybe if you think about you can't ask a
man on a street to give a sperm sample
right so a man has to volunteer and he
has to usually have a motivation to do
that and maybe he's doing that because
he's going to get a vasectomy then he
has very good sperm count right because
he's had a lot of children or maybe he's
doing that cuz he's having trouble
conceiving and then he has low sperm can
so the selection of the population is
really important right right so there
were 61 studies and so I took out of
those 61 studies I got them retrieved
them looked through them and took out of
them any information I had on these and
other relevant factors I also took out
what country they were conducted in and
and so on and so forth all the details I
could about the study and then I and my
colleagues put them in a you know
spreadsheet and ran a more complicated
analysis than had been done before so we
called it multivariable because he had
all these variables in there right not
just looking at the decline and Danny it
was staggering to see that after all
that work of 6 months and accounting for
all these factors the slope changed from
-93 to
-95 it didn't change at all right that's
million sperm per milliliter per year
and wow I just like I went back to the
committee and I said I can't make this
go away it looks like it's real it's so
I mean it's so unusual in science to see
that that consistency you know so I
thought okay this is something I really
have to look at and so she began running
studies herself with her most important
study in 1999 where she measured the
sperm count of men at sperm donor
clinics in four cities Los Angeles
Columbia Minneapolis and New York what I
did I I I selected four cities in the
United States with different
environments and I recruited the men in
exactly the same way so there wasn't
problem with selection bias and I can
I'll tell you in a minute how we did
that and then we measured the sperm
exactly the same way in each of the four
centers you can't get Seaman from a man
on the street you can't get a random
Sean sample right you just can't do it
okay so I decided that the group that
absolutely always goes for medical care
is pregnant women almost always right so
I decided to recruit pregnant women in
order to recruit their husbands kind of
Dev maybe we weren't asking them for a
lot we were asking them the women for a
urine sample and a questionnaire and a
blood sample but they give that anyway
when they're pregnant you know so it
wasn't really uh an
imposition and then from the husbands we
wanted in addition a semen sample right
so we got over 900 men and women to do
this yeah approximately equally
distributed amongst our centers and then
we looked at their seing quality and
what we found was absolutely alarming
and unexpected and what we found was
that the men living in Central Missouri
in Colombia had half half as many moving
sperm as men in
Minneapolis wow that's what I said wow
and is that that's obviously due to okay
Sor don't know don't jump there but your
question I know where you're going
you're going to say agriculture
pesticides she suspected that the high
use of pesticides in Colombia the
agricultural capital of the US was
causing lower than normal sperm count it
turns out very luckily for us that you
can measure pesticide exposure in the
urine and I remember I told you that we
got the men's urine yes so and we got
that at the same time they gave a semen
sample okay all right so we could ask
okay are the levels of pesticides in the
men's urine at that time when they gave
the seam sample related to their sperm
quality at that time and the answer was
yes and we found five pesticides that
were very different between men who had
very good semen quality and very poor
semen quality in U Missouri in there our
Center in Missouri five different
pesticides yeah wow Dr Swan have found
the Smoking Gun pesticides specifically
the hormone disrupting chemicals found
in pesticides was what was causing the
sperm count in Colombia to drop but it
wasn't just adult men that was affected
women and even unborn babies were being
affected by these chemicals and it
didn't take long for Dr Swan to narrow
down the type of chemicals that was
causing this Fates Fates Fates Fates and
phalates are everywhere Fates are in
soda bottle shampoo lotion perfume flame
rars clothing it's literally in
everything you are in contact with
phades pretty much all day long and once
you touch them those phet get absorbed
into your skin these chemicals are so
dangerous to our hormones and fertility
that it's not only annihilating sperm
count but as Dr Swan puts it these
chemicals can quote interfere with
complex biochemical Pathways in the
brain in ways that may affect how a
person expresses their gender End quotes
that quote the changes in sexual
development taking place all over the
world appear to have been accompanied by
an apparent rise in gender fluidity End
quotes at its minimum photes are making
you infertile it's making men's penises
shorter and perhaps it's making us more
gay and at its worse this dropping sperm
count can lead to the extinction of the
human species if it were to continue on
its present in course well that's a
difficult thing to project of course but
just mathematically if you extended the
line it does hit zero in
2045 so that's the median sperm count
that means half of men would have no
sperm and yet the companies producing
these chemicals are not going to stop
anytime
[Music]
soon
after further investigation Dr Swan
discovered that if a pregnant mother was
exposed to Phish during the first
trimester of pregnancy her son would go
on to develop a misformed small penis
sometimes called the taint or the GU or
the grundle very familiar with the go
when the mother let's say rat was
exposed to a phite let's just say I'm
going to give you name diethyl hexal
phalate DP just so I can talk about it
that's probably the most the worst actor
in this class for lowering testosterone
when the mother was exposed to that in
early pregnancy then her male offspring
developed smaller penises smaller
scrotum testes were less likely to
descend and there were internal changes
as well changes to the vast deference
and and so epidemis and so on and this
distance that they'd been measuring for
years but which I and no other
epidemiologists had not heard about the
distance from the anus to the genitals
became
shorter and they called it the thite
syndrome when the mother was given
thides in her food at that time
testosterone is surging that the surge
is wiped out it's eliminated the graph
is very dramatic right it just
completely flat in males genetic males
so that says that that male need needs
that testosterone at that time to
develop normally so it's not about just
avoiding Fates in plastic as an adult
man we actually get our hormones
affected in the womb so if a mother is
exposed to phalates between days 18 and
21 of gestation if the mother is exposed
during that very exact window this burst
of testosterone will be blocked and the
male baby will be born with things like
a smaller penis a shorter adg and just
have like General trouble producing
sperm and all that good stuff it's such
a delicate thing and it only takes a
tiny bit amount of phades to block the
hormones some scientists say it's like
the equivalent of a drop of oil and an
olympic size swimming pool that's the
ratio we're working with here and it's
like that small amount of phades can
make major damage this is Robert Oliver
by the way he's the founder of top shelf
ground which you might have seen on
Amazon he's a great friend and he's
always been obsessed over optimizing his
health and the craziest part of all this
is that being exposed to these chemicals
before you're born won't just affect the
way you look but it can actually change
your brain chemistry and how you behave
later on in life
my suspicion is that just as the
generals differentiate into male and
female the brain also does one study
showed that when male monkey babies were
exposed to BPA a fet f in plastic they
showed more feminine behaviors like
clinging to their mothers and social
exploration they can produce rats and as
I told you that want to have males want
to have sex with other males really yes
that can be produced with the pesticide
we talked about before atrazine right
and this was a study that was done on
fish and frogs as well right right frogs
particularly frogs oh yes they made
homosexual frogs fets can also make
girls act more masculine one study
showed that little girls who were
exposed to dioxin exhibited more
masculine behaviors than girls who
weren't you're not totally doomed if
you're exposed to Fates Fates are water
soluble and only last in your system for
around 24 hours when you're exposed but
most people literally always have fetes
in their system either from breathing
and pesticides all day washing their
hands with soap drinking from plastic
bottles and the list goes on Fates are
encar body care products like body wash
and deodorant fragrance may contain what
does it mean may contain it might
contain up to like 20 or 30% of fatties
wow and we found a lot of parabens
they're in your clothes in your
furniture store Rees on the inside of
soda cans polyester is polyethlene tear
off salate be careful with coffee be
careful with soda cans those aluminum
cans yeah those are lined in Plastics
too phate containing plastic or BP
bisphenol containing plastic like B BPS
or BPF so Plastics Plastics everywhere
uh again with the blankets they snake
them into perfumes these things are
freaking everywhere like I just said
they're ubiquitous and even if you did
manage to escape all these chemicals our
modern lifestyle is already making us
infertile
anyways
[Music]
back in the early 1900s most men spent
all day working on farms they're
constantly in motion this kept their
testosterone and sperm count high but
today's men spend hour sitting at a
cramped desk staring at a screen only to
go home to stare at more screens and
while they've n themselves with porn and
social media and stuffed their faces
with fake foods and this is destroying
their sperm I was shocked to see this
like screens affect sperm so that's kind
of bizarre staring at your phone or
watching too much TV can affect your
sperm count yeah that that being a couch
potato actually it's it's tied to that
so you're watching your screen you're
not outside exercising you're not riding
your bike you're not right so these are
never one factor at a time it doesn't
have so much to do with like the lights
going into your retinas it's more to do
with like when people are connected to
screens they're sitting down and they're
inactive that's right sugary sodas lower
sperm cigarettes lower sperm meat and
dairy from cow fed estrogens lower sperm
tyol lower sperm and the list goes on so
right at the top there you want to avoid
avoid foods with any pesticides so any
grains sprayed with pesticides corn a
lot of Oats grown in the US have
glycophosphate non-organic wheat moving
down that list we've got things like
Tylenol lowering sperm count biking so
even if it's just you know couple hours
a week that can lower your sperm count
by 34% saunas hot tub any kind of
extreme heat in general can lower sperm
count it's actually one of the worst
things alcohol especially if you're
drinking alcohol like your uh like a
sixth grader so drinking it early in
life can really really stunt development
in manhood there's a lot of stuff that
Society tends to deem healthy and like
acceptable so you see you look around
you see everyone doing it like how many
people eat oatmeal right and at the end
of the day those are actually destroying
our health and the crazy thing is that
all this destruction to your hormones
can be passed down through entire
Generations so if you want to prevent
all this damage to your sperm and
hormones the absolute best thing you can
do is get your own farm grow your own
food and clock out of modern society
completely which is actually starting to
become appealing but obviously that is
not going to work for most of us so you
want to do what you can you want to only
eat organic you want to cut out as much
plastic out of your life as possible
we're talking food containers utensils
water bottles and ideally you want to
cut out things like conventional
deodorant body wash shampoo lotion and
swap them out for more natural versions
because these chemicals are very easily
absorbed through the skin and obviously
if you're still eating fake processed
food and not exercising what are you
doing just start with those and you'll
get like 50 to 80% of the benefits those
are the Baseline things you need to be
doing but if you want to boost you might
want to check out Ros brand kingmaker
with the link below King maker is the
testosterone supplement to end all
testosterone supplements it has 12
clinically studied ingredients in the
right doses so it actually makes a
difference when you take it unlike most
fake supplements it does not have a
proprietary blend so you can actually
see what's in it and what amounts on the
label and because Rob uses real
ingredients in the right doses it costs
Rob as much money to make King maker as
what other fake testosterone supplements
are selling for so King maker is not
cheap but that is also exactly what
you're looking for in a supplement like
this I take R's products myself every
day I love them that's why I'm happy
that King maker is sponsoring this video
and you can pick up some for yourself
with the link below because if you don't
do anything about your sperm C and
hormones this destruction is going to be
passed down to your kids and your kids
[Music]
kids the world economic Forum keeps
telling us that our population is out of
control there's too many people on earth
and US dirty overpopulated humans are
destroying the environments but the swan
studies paint a different picture for
fertility for PCOS for miscarriage for
testosterone they're all declining at at
least 1% per year you know Tom when I
say to people 1% per year they go yeah
that's a lot then I say 50 years that's
how far back we've looked that's 50% at
least see she says we're at a Tipping
Point where fertility will go down
enough to cause the population to shrink
she says that if male fertility keeps
dropping at 1% per year like it is right
now in a few years Mei and sperm count
will l literally be zero let me say that
again median sperm count will literally
go to zero and the reason for this is
because low sperm count can actually be
passed down through generations if you
have phallic in your sperm and you get a
woman pregnant that embryo is way more
likely to develop malform genitals
undesended testicles and yes even a micr
penis yeah so it's crazy but like
phalates definitely alter the DNA of the
sperm and so it like quite literally
changes the quality so if you have
genetically weak sperm creating an
embryo that embryo will be genetically
weak and it'll grow up a genetically
weak boy or girl you see what I'm saying
with all this it's faulty DNA that is
created with ballet exposure and then
that's just passed down and it's
something that your great great
grandchildren can be exposed to at the
end of the day right and that's kind of
the whole we've gotten so good at
keeping people alive and functioning
longer lifespans but less quality of
life that this is like textbook that
right weaker sperm is created weaker
humans are created we've gotten good
enough to keep them alive and and let
them reproduce right so they're not
dying off in a way that would have you
know previously happened and we have
generations of weak individuals your son
will grow up with lower sperm quality as
well and will probably have trouble
having kids in the future he would then
pass on this faulty DNA to his son and
this is how the male fertility death
Spar will starts it's a slow invisible
chemical Extinction of our species and
this chemical Extinction is already
happening in the animal kingdom one
group of male polar bears in Greenland
who are exposed to high amounts of
pesticides has super low testosterone
levels short penises and smaller than
normal testicles in a pesas contaminated
lake in Canada alligators only had a 5%
hatch rate when usually it's 85% and the
minks who live near the lake also had
abnormally small penises and bald eagles
exposed to DDT are laying eggs so thin
that when they send on them the eggs
instantly crack fet and our horrible
lifestyles are slowly killing us off and
the big companies who manufacture these
chemicals know this they are perfectly
aware with how dangerous these chemicals
are but do you think they're going to
stop
[Music]
when did this stuff start getting into
our food supply has that been estimated
the growth of these chemicals tracks
with the growth of the petrochemical
industry because they're made from
petrochemical byproducts two of the
biggest sources of Phi are pesticides
and Plastics both are made from the
byproducts of the oil and gas industry
and guess what plastic raked in around
$130 billion just last year while
pesticides red in around $80 billion so
put yourself in the shoes of these
corporations are they going to stop no
if you're in their shoes you're going to
keep the plastic making machine oiled
and running for as long as you possibly
can and if you're one of these companies
in the US you're actually in luck
because the EPA doesn't really have the
money to regulate your toxic fetes why
would they spend their valuable time in
money on an obscure invisible chemical
that isn't visibly hurting people right
this instant when you can focus on the
more popular chemicals like carcinogens
for example because there are so many
dangerous chemicals around that EPA
pretty much lets any chemical be used in
manufacturing only once a chemical has
been proven to be toxic will it then be
reviewed and hopefully banned but this
reviewing period can take decades
sometimes an entire century and if one
of the chemicals is shown to be toxic
like BPA was 11 years ago the great
thing about chemistry is that you can
just reformulate the chemical
composition just a tiny bit and you can
slap on a new name to it and voila it's
legal again when in practice is
basically the same exact toxic thing the
reality is though BPA got a bad R and so
manufacturers seized on this and they
said well I'm going to sell BPA free
everything they took out BPA but they
replaced it with its chemical cousin BPS
or bisphenol S the toxicological profile
looks exactly the same darn near similar
to BPA so how do we fix this do we a
stop using Plastics B stop using
pesticides or C do we keep using all of
those things and just make artificial
sperm if you chose C ding ding ding you
would be
[Music]
correct pictur list the year is 2045 men
across the world are all infertile so
what do people turn to well it sounds
horrifying but scientists are already
experimenting with lab grown sperm a
French startup company says it's reached
a breakthrough creating human sperm in a
lab for the first time scientists say
they have succeeded in creating
functioning sperm ah yes lab grown sperm
and this artificial sperm will probably
be used to grow artificial humans in an
artificial womb but if you don't want to
opt into this dystopia you want to do
all the stuff we talked about earlier
but by far the most important thing you
want to do especially if you're a guy
that has a low testosterone right now is
to avoid these scummy telea Health
companies like him you've probably seen
ads for hims before hims uses their cute
little breing to pray on insecure men
when messaging like trouble getting hard
feeling stress or burnt out want to last
longer in bed you don't have to change
your diet exercise or get more sunlight
no just get prescribed our terrible
pharmaceutical drugs online and since
these drugs only fix the symptoms of
erectile dysfunction or depression and
not the root cause you'll be dependent
on our drugs for life and for that him
has to become a billion dooll company
and Rob exposes it all in his new video
that you can watch right now by clicking
the card on the screen it's a super good
video if you like our videos you are
going to love his so click the card on
the screen to watch
[Music]
now